el objetivo de este vídeo es escribir
los números del 0 al 100 pero de una
manera interesante que nos permita
observar un patrón así que vamos a
empezar el primero voy a escribir los
números del 0 al 9 a ver 0
8 y 9 muy bien
y para continuar quiero hacerlo de esta
manera a ver observemos voy a tomar el
renglón que acabo de escribir que está
aquí y lo voy a copiar y pegar
lo copió y lo pego y ahora vamos a
ponerlo aquí abajito y en que nos puede
ayudar pues sabemos que el 10 es un 1
seguido de un 0 el 11 es un 1 seguido de
un 1 el 12 es un 1 seguido de un 2 y
luego viene el 13 el 14 el 15 el 16 17
18 y 19 y algo muy interesante en lo que
acabamos de hacer es que la siguiente
línea de números o sea los que van del
10 al 19 los podemos pensar de la
siguiente manera es decir que el 1 que
acabo de poner representa un 10 o sea
este que está aquí es 10 y 10 + 0 pues
es 10 el 11 pues no es otra cosa que 10
más 1 y el 12 es
10 2 es decir el siguiente renglón que
yo puse los números que van del 10 al 19
es muy similar al renglón anterior en
cuanto a que están los números amarillos
del 0 al 9 pero agregamos un 1 a la
izquierda con valor 10
vamos a ver si esto funciona y vamos a
construir el siguiente renglón
así que a ver vamos a poner el siguiente
renglón y qué es lo que obtendríamos
vamos a ver esto con cuidado
bueno pues después del 19 viene el 20 y
el 20 lo obtenemos escribiendo un 2
seguido de un 0 entonces tengo 20 21 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 y 29 muy bien vamos a
ver si esto sigue funcionando
voy a poner otro renglón
muy bien ahora vamos a ponerlo en su
posición
perfecto y está muy bien después del 29
viene el 30 si yo pongo un 3 seguido de
un 0 obtengo el 30 un 3 seguido de un 1
el 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 y 39 muy bien
y en este punto podemos observar ya el
patrón interesante es decir en todos los
renglones se repiten los números del 0
al 9 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y luego los
números entre el 10 y el 19 agregamos un
1 a la izquierda luego están los 20 en
los cuales se repite un 2 en cada número
del renglón luego vienen los treintas
que tiene un 30 a la izquierda de cada
uno de los números amarillos en ese
renglón bien pues quiero terminar de
rellenar todos los números y esta vez
utilizando otra idea veamos primero voy
a poner todos los renglones de los
dígitos amarillos del 0 al 9 a ver
primero voy a poner los renglones en con
los números amarillos a ver entonces
tenemos
este que está aquí que puede
corresponder al 40 luego vamos a tener
este que está aquí que va a corresponder
a los del 50
luego
gente que va a ser de los sesentas
y luego tenemos este que está aquí
atentas
luego este que está aquí para los
ochentas muy bien
y luego
siguiente para los noventas
y bien como habíamos dicho ahora voy a
tener aquí el 40
el siguiente va a ser para los 50s el
siguiente a ver déjame ver otro color
que no haya usado va a ser para los
sesentas luego el siguiente el siguiente
va a ser para el 70 luego tendré el 80
y finalmente tendré el 90
muy bien y para completar mi tarea ahora
voy a hacer lo siguiente voy a tomar
estos números que acabo de escribir los
copio y los pego y ahora lo voy a poner
en este lugar y obtengo el 41 51 y los
que siguen lo vuelvo a pegar y obtengo
el 42 52 62 72 82 y 92 lo pego yo tengo
el 43 53 hasta el 93 lo vuelvo a pegar y
ahora obtengo el 44 54 64 74 84 y 94
vuelvo a ponerlos
para obtener 45 55 65 75 85 y 95 vuelvo
a poner los y obtengo el 46 56 66 76 86
y 96 y los siguientes
nos vamos a poner aquí y el siguiente y
se observa lo que estamos
haciendo el patrón con el que estamos
trabajando
y finalmente los que corresponden al 49
59 69 79 89 y esto funciona muy bien
bueno y para finalizar pues pongamos al
100 y para poner el 100 pues sólo
necesito poner un cero y luego poner
junto a el 110 10 seguido de un 0 es 100
esto estuvo genial